الكوالم
جواب السجنسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ان تصبح رئيسا لبلد من خلال انتخابات
ديمقراطيه وتحافظ على شعبيتك طوال عقدين
ولو بمعدلات متفاوته فهذا لا يمنحك الحصان
من انتقاد الاعلام الغربي خاصه من الصحف
المدافعه عن قيم الديمقراطيه هنا تجتمع
مؤسسات اعلاميه كبرى مثل
تتبنى خطابا مناهضا للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان يصفونه بالمستبد ويربطون فوزه
بالخراب والاضطرابات وينشرون رسوما تسخر
من طريقه حكمها وحتى شكله وبعضها يذهب الى
ابعد من شخص اردوغان ويتحكم برموز الدوله
مثل الهلال التركي المحطم في هذه الصوره
في داش بيجل الالمانيه فلسفه هذا الخطاب
ليست قائمه على الانتقاد في حد ذا لكل
الاطراف السياسيه في تركيا بلن معظم هذه
الصحف تروج بشده لزعيم المعارضه التركيه
فما سر هذا الانحياز الكبير وهل يتنافى
هذا الخطاب مع مواثيق الاعلام
مناطقه
قيامه
حجه هذه الصحف في انتقاد اردوغان هي وجوده
على هرم السلطه منذ عام 2002 وان كان هذا
النموذج لا يعد استثناء في دول تحتكم الى
الصندوق لتبديل رؤسائها ومن ابرز الامثله
انجيلا ميركل التي حكمت المانيا 16 عاما
او بنيامين نتنياهو صاحب اطول مده حكم في
تاريخ دوله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والذي
يواجه اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم حرب خلال
الحرب على غزه عام 2014 بسبب استهداف
قواته الفرق الطبيه وقد تصدر مذكره
لاعتقاله من المحكمه الجنائيه وفق صحيفه
يسال الكاتب التركي احسان اكتاش عن سر
ازدواجيه الاعلام الغربي في تغطيه الاحداث
التركيه مقارنه بدول اخرى الصحف نفسها
التي تنتقد اردوغان تصمت تماما عن زعماء
وصلوا الى الحكم بانقلابات دمويه ومنهم من
يواجه اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم حرب يرى
اكتاش ان هذا النهجه سببه سعي غربي لاحياء
العصر الاستعماري والوصايه على تركيا تضع
هذه الصحف لنفسها مسوغات للخروج عن مبادئ
الصحافه حين تتعامل مع الملفات الخارجيه
وخاصه ملف دول الشرق الاوسط لكن هذا النهج
يعد خطا احمر في ميزان القضايا المؤثره في
الشعب الاوروبي او الامريكي هنا مثلا
يواجه مالك محطه فوكس نيوز الامريكيه
موقفا في قمه الحرج فهو لم يعلن مناصره
ترامب ولم يصف بايدن بامير الفوضى مثل ما
يفعل الاعلام في تغطيته المتحيزه
للانتخابات التركيه ورغم ذلك وجها
انتقادات لان المحطه استضافت شخصيات مؤيده
لفرضيه تزوير الانتخابات وتناقلت معلومات
مصدرها محامي يوترامب
هذه ليست للمره الاولى
وطوال مده
حملات كثيره تزامن معظمها مع الانتخابات
التي فاز في جميعها في النهايه هنا مثلا
تصف فورن بوليسي اردوغان بطاغيه في طور
التكوين وان بقائه في السلطه يعني ان لا
امل في الشرق الاوسط هذا المقال نشر قبيل
انتخابات 2014 التي حقق فيها العداله
والتنميه فوزا ساحقا
برايك لماذا يغضب الاعلام الغربي من
اردوغان